and let's read that first story and talk
about the babylon b
there's a lot here that i find
interesting this is a story we have from
timcast.com babylon be locked out of
twitter for man of the year satire quote
if the cost of telling the truth is the
loss of our twitter account then so be
it said the ceo of the christian-based
satire news site so they received a
notification from twitter saying that
their tweet has violated their rules
against promoting violence threatening
harassing
other people on the basis of race
ethnicity national origin sexual
orientation gender gender identity
religious affiliation age disability or
serious disease they said you can start
your countdown and continue to twitter
uh to twitter so it says once you delete
the content that violates our rules one
tweet
if you think we've made a mistake
contact us so the ceo is saying he won't
be taking it down
this is the post in question or this is
one of them it says the babylon b's man
of the year is rachel levine of course
rachel levine is a trans woman hence the
the joke they were making twitter says
this violated the rules so there's
something interesting here in that one i
think we can we can discuss uh the ceo's
unwillingness to take down the post he's
saying we're not going to do it but also
it's curious that
twitter
under uh section 230 which grants this
immunity to these tech platforms it says
that you can remove content that you
find to be objectionable or you know
lewd or lascivious or whatever
in this instance
and actually truth be told this is this
is typically how twitter does it
they make you remove it so right now
this is where it's interesting seth
dillon has said the tweet they say
breaks the rules is still up available
to be retweeted and seen by everyone and
it's going viral as people keep
retweeting it
why would he take that tweet down if he
believes in it and why wouldn't twitter
take it down if they think it's wrong
that's that's what i find fascinating
about this story other than
there's the whole culture war aspect of
one perspective is allowed in one
perspective isn't but i'm curious if you
guys have anything it feels like a
parent making a kid clean up their own
mess
as punishment
that's kind of interesting because it's
not just saying we don't like what you
said it's also almost like a form of
humiliation because they're like you
also have to take it down it's not
enough that you be punished for this you
have to do it yourself like one of those
uh those what are they those classes
where they get you to say something you
don't believe until you start to believe
it it's a struggle session yeah like a
struggle session yeah apparently they're
doing that in prisons i didn't i don't
like this because
the the terms say if it promotes
violence against threatens or harasses
now this tweet does not promote violence
against anyone or threaten anyone but
you could say that it's a harassment
thing i don't think i think this is an
abuse of the word harassment for the
terms like it's a one-off tweet it's a
public figure
uh i don't see any kind of of of
consistent harassment for a claim and
and the guy can always block it anyway
so
i i this i just feel like it's so
heavy-handed i think it depends on your
definition of harassment i mean if if
you're a trans person is being
misgendered the same way as if i call
you a i don't know
you know bad word for female genitalia
right right you know there's a
if you're if i'm if i'm using it and i'm
saying something that you feel is
insulting is that harassment but then
again if that's the rule the reason i
deleted twitter is because that's
literally all it is yeah this is the
first time in a long time i thought i
might actually just delete my i deleted
mine three years ago because pretty much
like it's just all that non-stop all day
long just yeah we were talking about on
the show like last week that twitter
only exists to emotionally destroy
people yeah i mean you have when you
have back when you had only 140
characters to express something it
rewards negative impulsivity in the
worst possible way and when i started
doing it that's when i deleted it i
started uh my twitter account 2008. um
and i i would make youtube videos 0607
and i was like text is the devil do not
rely on text for communication verbal
communication is how we get along this
text is and people like ian you're such
an idiot text is fine man twitter's cool
and then all these people start tweeting
and now you see the age of
miscommunication and there's a reason
for this because people are etching
markings on a wall and expecting someone
else to know what they meant
yo twitter is the word that's pretty bad
it brings out the worst in people yeah
and like this i i would say okay you
should be allowed to make a joke
whatever but at the same time i look at
it and i go what am i gaining from
making that joke you know
like i believe in the right to be able
to say something like that but i just i
wouldn't use it if it's just gonna piss
a bunch of people off and i don't gain
anything from calling this person a man
versus a woman or whatever well i'll say
i think that
the babylon b is a christian site they
have a perspective right yeah and it's
also meant for humor and it's a satire
so they're going to say things that are
shitpost that are going to aggravate
people right right i mean comedy is
offensive or at least it used to be
supposed to i don't know what left-wing
comedy is right now there's this there's
this youtuber guy and he um someone
posted this in response to seth dillon
he's the ceo and it was like why
conservative comedy isn't funny and it's
just like a weird thing to claim to like
it's
look i understand the left is going to
pile on this dude who wrote why
conservative commas isn't funny like
they're going to they're going to go and
comment like we know we know it's so
true conservative comedy isn't funny and
i'm just like
yo
it's subjective i've never watched
liberal versus conservative commentator
like when you when you look at let's say
bill bill burr i think would be more
left than my other people here what you
have when you listen to his 2012 special
on gold digging horrors and beating
women i mean would that come out in 2022
no no no no i'm surprised he hasn't
gotten his head chopped off for doing
that every now and then i'll watch that
and just like laugh hysterically
next to me i don't understand the idea
of like what conservative comedy is
you know that's the weirdest thing that
the response on the left is like you're
not funny so it's not a joke i think
you're talking about greg gutfield
versus uh what's the other guy like seth
meyers or something like that but that
stuff's not funny to me i don't enjoy
either funny i mean but but i i don't i
don't ideologically possess comedy sucks
in my opinion yes i i
not necessarily it depends if it speaks
to your ideology you're going to enjoy
it
so that's why i say it's subjective when
there there was a vice special i saw
where it was a transgender comedian
and they were explaining how to do
comedy properly you make fun of yourself
that we're not hurting anybody and
there's no oppression and it was a bunch
of people in the audience and the person
on stage was like a tall skinny trans
woman who was constantly talking about
how awful they were to themselves and
the audience was laughing like no one's
getting hurt because they're making the
joke about themselves they seem to enjoy
it i'm just like i mean i'm not going to
rag on somebody look if you want to make
a video game or a movie or a show and
you want to go and you enjoy it like man
go do your thing i got nothing to do
with it if i want to watch dave
chappelle don't get him canceled from
netflix because you don't like it like
you're offended by it so
you know gutfeld i think gut felt on fox
is more like a
observational humor but not i wouldn't
put comedy first it's like a it's a it's
a political commentary show with snark
which makes you laugh some depending on
his audience you know it's one of the
biggest shows seth meyers does the same
for the left maybe you want to argue
that they're only laughing with the left
like they're being told to laugh or
whatever look if people want to watch it
and they get millions of views they do
same with colbert i i had an issue a
couple nights ago i was watching like
the epic fails compilations on youtube
you ever watch those where it's just
like epic fails and you see people
falling down and slipping on ice and
like tumbling into the ocean and stuff
and i was laughing but it wasn't comedy
that wasn't comedy it's people getting
hurt and people falling down but i was
laughing so i was laughing at something
that wasn't comedy it's possible that
what people consider comedy is actually
not it might something or some things
that's funny isn't necessarily comedy i
was i remember when i was little i was
watching it was america's funniest home
videos oh yeah i think it was bob saget
and uh maybe i'm misremembering this
because it's been like 30 years or
something but it was a guy skiing and he
trips and starts tumbling down the
mountain and and bob sagan was going
like nope
don't wrote like like whoopsie falling
and i'm like thinking to myself i'm like
is that man very hurt
i'm confused like what's happening and
it was something like that maybe maybe
i'm you know remembering it too harshly
because i was like a little kid so i
think that when people make fun of
themselves in comedy it's kind of like
that you're laughing because you see
someone hurting themself in front of you
but it's not funny it's not well it's
funny but it's not comedy at least in my
opinion i don't like that
self-depreciating stuff i got i mean
it's all right rodney dangerfield did it
okay bill burr was all right with it but
dangerfield would rip on his wife too so
he like no one was sacred you know
i've been i've been thinking about
like the the the pronouncement to the
the um
the culture war is just getting so
insane
that
when we say there's no middle ground
there's literally like we're well beyond
any kind of reasonable logic
so you know i'm gonna bring it up
because i i really want to but i had
this tweet last like this weekend about
going to a diner yeah it was like friday
or something yeah where i was like i
went to a diner with my girlfriend and
we were we were they told us 20 they
said it was a 20-minute wait
and then uh they seated other people
before us so i complained and left and
like the point of my tweet was one i'm
kind of irritable you know so that's
like not a positive statement about
myself but that you know it serves me
well in my work in business that i don't
tolerate any kind of you know impedance
so if they're like oops we seated
someone else before you i'll just be
like i'll go somewhere else like i got
no issue i'm not gonna bother i'm not
gonna i'm gonna leave the weirdest thing
is how this became a culture war issue
it became political like on twitter on
reddit the right can't meme it's like a
subreddit where they just make fun of
like right-wing people they screen
grabbed it and they were like
i it was just like
making fun of me
for no reason on an in-name tweet having
nothing to do with politics and that's
what i wanted to bring that up because
you mentioned well for one i wanted to
bring it up but also you mentioned how
it's just like negative impulses on
twitter and i'm like i didn't i didn't
talk smack about anybody like i i
typically i i
i was about to tweet about aoc last week
and it was like nasty and so i like
toned it way down like i want to make my
point
but i shouldn't insult her or anything
like i can i can you know criticize her
without just being stupid and childish
but man i think i i think you nailed it
when you said it's just it drives
negative impulses i also think as we
mentioned before it exists just to
emotionally destroy people the one area
where i would disagree with you is where
you said that there's no middle ground
in the culture where it's either here or
here the middle ground is not on there
and the tablet it's out there like every
time i go outside and i talk to somebody
in a line at a grocery store it was a
date i was on two weeks ago with
somebody who i thought would absolutely
horribly like hate me over with their
their position they said you know like
she actually asked me she's black
because you know she's more left than i
am she's what do you think of blm and i
said you're okay this is gonna be fun
i'm a white store
that was like there with the
activating a 400 watt air horn on my
phone every time i heard somebody
banging on the door uh june 2020. and it
was actually a very very reasonable
conversation i heard where she was
coming from she heard where i was coming
from that doesn't happen on twitter that
doesn't happen oh for sure but like this
happens at the line at the grocery store
this happens at the gym this happens at
you know a martial arts class it happens
almost everywhere just doesn't happen on
the internet because they said there's
something about um how people act when
they're behind a screen that changes
their entire perspective and i think the
fact that all the political
conversations that we're having now
versus 20 or 30 or 40 or 50 years ago
are not in person where there's always
that thought of
you know i could get punched in the face
exactly wasn't it mike tyson yeah yeah
that that motto that modifies people and
for the last two months i've spent way
more time uh avoiding my youtube comment
section avoiding social media and
actually engaging with people in reality
or you know sitting next to them at a
steakhouse or a bar and talking and it's
it's a radically different world there
is a middle ground like most people are
in that middle ground it's just they're
out there they're not on the internet
wow well so the problem is before you
even get a chance to have that middle
ground before that conversation
the internet is sort of
gaining more and more ground the other
thing more more control you don't know
like if you see somebody's facebook post
where they say all this other stuff it
may kind of aggravate you already
because like wait i don't agree with you
here this that and the other and you're
immediately going to be arguing instead
of just asking questions so what do you
think of this and then i give my
perspective you give yours you have a
kind of a back and forth you're already
aggravated when you read somebody who's
used their limited 140 characters to
come up with the most uh douchey way to
say that they don't like something yeah
or a way to aggro like there was this
one article i read recently it was about
the
it was about lawn signs and it was
something on the lawn sign you know in
this household we believe that women's
rights are everybody's rights uh you
know no person is illegal this that and
the other and it's like there's not real
like that that sign is an f you
republican sign it's not an actual i
believe in all this and it also doesn't
necessarily invite discussion the same
way that the whole uh you know like you
owe me gas money sign with like biden
with neck with like um i did that and
aziz
you uniform and all that that's
that that meaning culture and all that
that doesn't open you to a discussion
the same way that just oh you know
you're sitting next to somebody in a
space that's not the intent the intent
is to create a perception of majority so
the biden stickers the goal of that is
so that regular people will see biden
being made fun of and not want to be in
the out group
so if there's someone who doesn't follow
politics and they go to a gas station
and they keep seeing the biden stickers
well then they're more likely to be like
oh yeah yeah i think biden's dumb like
because the perception is if most people
follow this you don't want to be in the
out group because the app group is
dangerous you lose access to resources
and humans have that natural survival
instinct the same thing is true for
putting flags on their porch or putting
that sign they want everyone to see the
signs and so that's one of the reasons i
say there's no middle ground
there is you know like you said outside
for for the average person but what
we're seeing more and more
like the reason i brought this up is
that the conversations around politics
have become
completely inane like
we're seeing more and more people being
made funneled for things that aren't
even political or conversations emerging
around things that aren't even political
or don't need to be i think everybody is
on edge to the point where they're just
waiting for the smallest thing to take
them off to lose it
yeah everybody is very very on edge and
walking just like vibrating with rage
well i think one of the issues is that
you have people who
it's it's an addiction it's a drug
addiction it's it's you want those hits
you want those clicks and you're trying
to find a way to get that satisfaction
so you want that tweet that's gonna get
a thousand retweets or whatever so you
have a lot of people on social media who
are constantly one-upping each other
taking it one step further left and
right because
they want people to react they want
people to share they won't be able to
respond and there's no point where
someone just like people need to start
toning things down i i certainly think
that there are
i i look my perspective and my bias is
fairly obvious on this one there's a
reason why i think in polling moderate
voters and republicans tend to agree on
a lot of issues and democrats are
completely in the out group relative to
those two groups or i should say the
democrats are isolated in their beliefs
independents and republicans overlap
massively on tons of issues and i think
it's because there's something just
generally tribalist and cultish of the
modern mainstream left and the things
they're pursuing you can get story after
story that turns out to be false and
they end up believing it you get
illogical uh statements like only white
people can be racist and candace owens
is a white supremacist things like that
that don't seem to make sense i think
economically a lot of people wind up
leaning a little more left but
culturally they wind up leaning right
because they think that type of stuff is
crazy when they hear that you know you
cannot be you cannot be racist if you're
here but you can be racist if you were
born this way like someone will hear
that and go what where i think that same
person would would probably prefer
medicare for all to the health care
system we have now where you get it you
like you uh you know you fall off a bike
and then you have a five thousand dollar
bill when you that you for spending 45
minutes in a hospital that you weren't
even awake for like that's right
or or even choose to go to sometimes but
this is way more overlapped than people
think like when you read the internet
you really think that okay because i've
heard you say this one thing i now know
what you think about these other 42
things but then when you actually go out
in the real world you realize that it's
not like that it's not just a you know a
clipboard where there's like a checkbox
of 42 different things but so so as much
as i would agree with you in a lot of
this um one of the challenges i see is
that
the the middle ground people aren't
active and so when we try and engage in
things they have jobs they have lives
they have things to do they're they're
out there doing everything this is what
i explained to you right for sure when
we try to do things however that we
think are like good politically i'll
give you an example a few years ago we
put on an event called ending violence
racism and authoritarianism and the
keynote speaker was a a very very famous
black jazz musician who de-radicalized
members of the clan
far left groups threatened to burn the
theater down and then showed up and
protested the theater canceled our
contract within two weeks so there was
not even an opportunity to have that
middle ground conversation in a public
setting we ended up having to move to a
venue with half the seats we were i
think 100 some odd people weren't able
to attend because of capacity issues so
while there are middle ground people who
are working and doing normal things if
we want to change things for the
positive but we're being shouted out and
screamed at by the squeaky wheel
demanding the grease then it is
eliminating any middle ground
opportunities for conversations
hyperpolarizing the conversation even in
the real world
i can see if you're not allowed to have
an event how that would be aggravating
yeah yeah the naming of that event i
took issue with when we were i was
working with bill we were kind of
formulating the idea putting the event
together i didn't end up going to that
event actually but i didn't like that it
was ending violence as opposed like
destroy evil as opposed to create good
like it's ha the phrasing what was the
argument from the people that wanted to
shut it down
uh
i mean not to be completely honest from
any uh
if i was to make an assumption based on
what i know about these people they
don't have one other than they must
shout down any and all individuals who
hold civil libertarian views so these
were anti-fuck uh critical race theorist
types and their their their whole
attitude is just prevent the
conversation from happening what was the
conversation that you were looking to
have that night
ending violence racism and authoritarian
authoritarianism so we actually had some
what was the conversation they thought
you were having
that's that's the conversation they
thought we were having daryl daryl davis
is very famous
i've heard of him yeah yeah
they don't look they don't look at our
event and see a mixture of different
voices across the political spectrum and
the headline the headliner was this
famous black man who de-radicalized clan
members who got a standing ovation they
don't see that and say from some
ex-grand wizard of the kkk or something
and there's a picture of him like after
oh no 200 clan members it's still
happening
in the mail i saw it i saw a two-hour
interview with him on rogan yeah he was
just on last week with bill yeah so your
minds you have a speaker like that
we had a mixture of some social justice
activists like left-wing individuals as
well as right-wing and libertarian
individuals and not a single white
nationalist or all-writer any of that it
was like a relatively s like centrist
libertarian slightly center right to
actual far leftist speaking there with
our headliner getting a standing ovation
from the audience there's no way they
look at that and they say these are
white supremacists now that's what they
told the press and the press
uncritically publishes it then they go
to the venue and say you have a bunch of
white supremacists we want you to cancel
it
apparently they threaten to burn the
theater down so the guy you know he
calls me and he's like shut it down no
business is going to want to be
associated with that that's the problem
and there's going to be very few that
are going to want to deal with the
aftermath after they've gotten your
money for one evening so so it sounds
like to go back to what you're saying
with the middle ground existing it
exists in small private underground
conversations that people can't find out
about i think it exists largely it's
just the people that were doing that are
the type of people who are going to
threaten the burner theater down they're
not the majority of middle ground people
they're a very small minority that just
so happens to be the loudest and the
most active the people that actually are
are in the middle ground there they have
lives like you know when i have
conversations with legislators i'll
often tell them when they'll go you know
there are 14 lobbyists against right to
repair now and one person here and i'll
go yeah they're on a farm
they're the reason that you have
something to eat they don't have time to
drive two hours and then sit here
waiting for three hours they could speak
for three minutes that's not a good use
of their time no offense i'm not trying
to be mean to you but they this is not
what they do the middle ground people
are out there making sure that we have
electricity and food and water and
computers and everything else they don't
have time for this [ __ ] they don't have
time to starting to burn a theater down
you're right uh the issue is they are
the majority what happens initially and
i agree but what happens initially is
that corporations and politicians only
hear one voice they hear the people who
are the loudest and they hear the people
who are the most obnoxious and the
people who are the most obnoxious are
often the people that don't have jobs
don't have lives don't care about their
reputation and
threaten to do things like that and so
what these legislators do is they assume
if regular working-class people won't
speak up for this
and won't have my back when i speak up
for them i won't so we had a we had a
guy in here terry schilling just last
week who said he runs an organization
that's basically the nra for families
and he was explaining how i believe was
the governor of north carolina is that
what he said i think so there was a
governor who said if you know if you
support a particular bill
all of like these conservative groups
are like we will have your back and he
was like okay and then when it came to
the politics they all abandoned him and
so he was like the only thing i see then
is the is the left coming out and using
force and actually following through
so that's that the issue i see is
moderates
don't really have advocates in my for
the most part because you know moderates
are moderate for a reason they're like
interested in hearing what you have to
say or they're undecided so you have you
know a variety of right a variety of
left and some centrist in between and
there's a conversation happening that
for the most part the right is unwilling
to stand up behind and the left is
absolutely willing to stand up and yell
about so you'll end up seeing amazon
walmart xbox all these video game
companies publishing statements in
support of black statements in support
of black lives matter and left wing
politics
then when it comes to the vote you end
up with a 2020 that looks very much like
it just did with the joe biden winning
and now you have all the politics that
come after it
i think for the most part now what's
happened in this country has become so
irrefutable that regular people are like
i'm voting republican the the general
ballot uh midterm general polling is
favoring republicans by like a 538 has a
2.4 and real clear politics is at 3.7
which is absurd because it's always
democrat up so now that's inverted
they're expecting it's going to be like
a crushing defeat for democrats
ultimately i don't think that'll solve
anything but the issue then becomes if
regular people don't really pay
attention because they're too busy with
their lives
then all that really ends up happening
is they'll say okay i'm not going to
vote for the democrat this time i'll
vote for the republican but the
republican is just democrat light it's
going to be the exact same policies the
exact same play the exact same
corporatism or at the very least they'll
say you know we're going to pause things
for here and then once democrats get
re-elected they kick things back into
high gear and keep moving forward
yeah
i'm uh i was just thinking about
about
creating the reality we want with our
words and how it's kind of disingenuous
to say like things are good if they're
not because it's
like you're a realist i'm kind of an
idealist in in this in this
description anyway we're both kind of
moderate but
there is something to saying like re
this is the way reality is just
describing the way you want it to be
even if it's not yet so that people
start to believe it and start to work
towards it but it's also disingenuous
when because this is like no truth but
power like you can't just say that
something is and then it expect it to be
like
but if you don't say that it is it's
never gonna happen so
i don't know man it's like you we need
we need like an ethical person to
manipulate people to the to the ends
that we need that it's going to be
better for the species nah see that's
the ends justifying the means ethical
manipulation sounds like a
yeah it does sounds crazy but that's
like what what this is literally like
having a conversation we're manipulating
each other with our words right now this
is this is like um what all of these big
ngos and you know global uh uh you know
billionaire types elites that's their
mentality i'm concerned that without a
leader
manipulation just going to get an
element of negativity to it i don't
think you're doing it with a negative
information
i'm manipulating this hat i'm i'm
holding it i'm moving it around
manipulating it yeah but you're talking
about manipulating a person you're
talking about
controlling them
into doing things you want you're
hugging your wife you're manipulating
her body you're manipulating her but
it's not a negative sense you know it
can be moderate it can even be good if
you're pulling someone out of a burning
fire you're manipulating them away from
the fire this is a justification for
authoritarianism well the thing is
without a leader i'm afraid that the the
the good u.s constitution is going to
get scrubbed and burned
yeah man
you know what
the rock and the hard place the reality
is that people on the right
be it you know and i mean this is the
colloquial culture war right which
includes center centrist libertarians
and like post-liberal types as well
that they don't stand up they don't go
out they almost never protest when
conservatives got in protest they get
smeared and slammed by the media and
labeled as all the worst things in the
world
and so
for that reason i think there's a
there's a good chance that uh you know
another now there's a good chance but
the left the cultural left the the
critical race theorists left all that
they've gained a lot of ground that
being said i think if you look at the
polling coming out of 538 nuclear
politics is the aggregates
the republicans and the cultural right
have probably gained way more ground and
like you're saying most people you know
are probably feeling this way more in
the middle than than anything else at
least out there in the real world the
question is
if the perception is that the majority
is on the left people will be unwilling
to speak out thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there